Oh have you seen any of the fan casting  for you as Batgirl because I also know  Nick ref and has spoken about directing  a Batgirl movie or at least what is so  funny about this because well Nick and I  Nick from the very start  like I don't know why I don't know why  he does this but from the moment like I  met him when I was 16 he my nickname is  Batgirl to him so he'll always and he's  a Robin Robin Wonder Boy so he'll say  like hey Batgirl like it's Robin like  always so like a wheat we were like just  joking like oh my god like are they  making this like Bert because he's  always called me that I feel like that's  a sign it's meant to be  yeah it's meant to be yeah I think Nick  I don't know if they would he'll do it  out their version ok super commercial it  would most certainly be unique